nathan fabien faut que je récupère ta
caméra pour te mettre tu sois là mais ça
je vais le faire maintenant et après on
est parti on veut lui faire des bulles
est ce soir fabien parce que je suis
très nul en ce moment comme dirait vlad
ces failles ce que c'est que en ce
moment pour te mais je pense pas que en
ce moment mais c'est notamment là je
suis particulièrement nul juste que
d'habitude puisque d'habitude mais bon
beaucoup de commentaires tu vois
beaucoup de et diouf fait longtemps que
j'ai pas eu le temps de jouer et donc il
faut que je reprenne ma forme donc c'est
ce qu'on va faire ce soir on va
récupérer notre forme pour pouvoir faire
des vidéos perez après mais là j'ai
besoin d'abord de tu vois pas ce que je
suis en perez mois mais vrai ce dernier
mouais c'est pas le top pour le moment
on va dire que ça va on te voit plus que
moi toi puisque moi mon ses parents on
va se mettre comme ça on va dire comme
ça allez on est pas mal on est pas mal à
laisser le beau jeu femme en est
repartie voir que je joue mieux que ce
que j'ai fait cet après midi j'ai eu une
petite heure et c'était afflige amants
de la merde serre que toi sur une
échelle de 1 à 10 de la merde en fait
aux échecs
j'étais plus proche du 10 / 10 / agence
était une figure artistique qu à un
espèce de concours de patinage ou quoi
je pense que les juges y met neuf voire
même 10 pour certains j'étais quand même
pas mal d'heures
c'était assez liquide c'était assez
liquide c'était du beau kaka
c'était c'était du beau kaka est là et
là on va essayer en fait de me faire un
peu mieux que ça mais ça commence déjà
très mal que tu vas aurait partie de
ceux qui ont internet est pourri mais il
peut me supporter dont l'essor est par
les gens me parlent et je vais voir le
chat j'ai dans mon disque attention à on
les dix déjà pas mal ben alors at on se
bat non mais attends je parle de la
position
là ça va lâcher en train de le fixer
l'âge en train de le fixer sur noir à la
fab je vais te commenté la partie comme
si tu étais dedans tu ne peux pas
l'avoir mais tu vas tu vas sentir
sablage et pris un gros risque
il ya peut-être des tactiques pour lui
ça va pour le moment y'a rien il ya non
ça marche pas je y avait une fourchette
c'est dur la fable là je suis dans le
dur je vois rien je me fais de nouveau
dominé mais ça va j'ai l'habitude ils se
parent avec son roi fable il vient y
vient il bien non ils changeront ils
changent d'avis il a changé de direction
il a fait une feinte de corps j'ai chopé
un pion j'ai chopé un pion fab femme
j'ai un plan de l'isf abjean ferme la
tour fab l'arrivée contre enferma tour
j'échange les tours j'ai changé pour
femmes mais ça va je pense que je le
tiens fab ça que j'ai en train d'envoyer
un pion là je suis en train d'envoyer un
pion annonce est en train de larguer
retiens aussi c'est chaud c'est chaud
bon en gros on a un pion de plus convard
perdre mais on va s'approcher d'un de
ses pions fable c'est le bordel j'ai du
mal à te on n'a plus que 6 second simple
on est mal autant femme mince non non
j'ai pris moore j'ai pris un nouveau
mauvais moment c'est horrible donc voilà
on est mal
c'est un truc qu'on peut faire c'est le
faire tomber on a une table de plus ça y
est on a gagné femme attend je suis en
train de je suis en train de décès de m
le chat bien c'était pour c'était
vraiment de la merde cette partie mais
je vous ai dit je suis passé tu sais
très laborieuse que je fais
c'est du liquide fab séduit kidal et on
va essayer le liquéfier justement lui
genre cette expression tu te liquéfie en
fait je sais pas si ça vient de ça en
fait au final
l'expression se liquéfier bon alors
attention fans j'ai un pion h3 et il a
plus de il a plus y en a qui est au tu
vois mais ils m'empêchent de roque et
moi je vais essayer de faire le rock que
j'appellerais le rock al hamedi donc le
par avec le roi
a fortiori savez je me suis barré avec
mauroy je suis le rock à la main mais
attaques sont trop prévisibles
ça manque de finesse en et 47 la tour de
main le chat ne dit pas grand chose dans
un mode et style à des trucs mais à
54,50 donc évasif et le beau jeu belge
fédéral fait le beau jeu je fais je vais
je me prends une marée pions jeu non
mais je dirais je suis complètement
récemment on voit les dragons go mais là
le problème c'est qu'ils ont là ils ont
des gros dragon enfin ils ont aussi un
dragon inn à tuer un dragon là ils ont
récupéré mais dragon
ils ont un vrai concours avec cracheurs
de glace à je suis en train d'essayer de
faire une menace par derrière
attention attention femmes suis en train
de passer par derrière
tu sais que c'est une de mes spécialités
il anime joson hawking diallo a de
nouveau parlé dans le chatt écrire ce
que vous voulez donc j'ai une connexion
kata je ne vois pas trop ce qui se passe
là cette chienne d'histoire le smecta
mois auquel son nom
je fais de la merde
non c'est pas possible c'est pas
possible
faut vraiment que je me réveille la face
c'est pas possible j'en ai marre ça me
fait penser dans les trucs de rue
gantois des trucs de rugby que je
t'envoie de temps en temps il ya un
entraîneur lancé l'entraîneur l'équipe
d'algérie de rugby et c'est le le fns
ouais et c'est le le le talk d'avant
match et ils leur disent ça fait ça fait
28 matches compères d'affilée j'en ai
plein les couilles de perdre si j'en
peux plus qu à l'isie j'en veux plus de
perdre
en fait ils ont perdu tous leurs matches
par exemple le le truc avec et sur
youtube
c'est avant un match ça se bat il
sélectionneur depuis 28 matches 28
défaites et il aura si j'en peux plus
quoi faire le mec de ne plus perdre et
j'en ai plein les couilles quoi je
clique ne sais pas je crois qu'ils
avaient prises et pris 50 points contre
l'équipe red toulouse le match précédent
les mecs dans le mékong ou plus mais qu
refuse de perdre et disions j'en peux
plus je ne peut plus perdre je ne joue
plus go je suis en train de le dominant
jean alemany comme boum boum boum boum
fab le mister cash flow dire favone bien
lier on va faire un stream stream de
coinche fois l'occasion pense à sa femme
ont un pion qui on a un pion qui file la
bonne fille film
en femme j'ai pas de plan je sais pas
comment la finir sa position on approche
des 100 on se bat j'ai un plan là qui
est en train d'arriver
j'ai un plan qui vient d'émerger j'ai
tout poussé fab
je suis en train de le mystifier fab
mystifié mystifie j'ai un deuxième qui
ont passé qui est parti je en train de
riz blé la gent train de faire des
vrilles j'ai mon deuxième pion qui va
devenir une dame fab quoi bon le tien
évolution il vient d'évoluer boom il a
abandonné boum boum boum boum ali
revient à l'effort enchaîné fab la
scandinave direct je pense je vais faire
une remontée d'affable en fait j'aime
bien essayer de bien jouer quand je suis
en très mauvaise forme en fait je trouve
quelque part c'est gratifiant de lutte
et tu vois j'ai connu ça au repos ne
s'est pas un bon feeling tournoi échec
l'échec à la double attaque des gages à
cavani boum boum boum boum boum tu
dégages avec tes pièces non mais j'en ai
marre c'est juste qu'à chaque fois que
les positions doivent être gagnante
comptait pas en forme il ya toujours un
truc qui permet de s'en sortir c'est
horrible j'ai déjà remarqué ça souvent
sophie ce soit dit allez 2006 ce soir là
et c'est l'objectif c'est de remonter à
2006 malgré la forme de merde et mr
coinchée il est important pour la france
justement
en tout cas ce qui est clermont fabre
c'est que j'envoie des pions ce soir
j'ai encore un pion sur la deuxième
rangée
c'est dans toutes les partitions qui
arrive en deuxième la semaine passée
déjà mais moi j'y arrive en huitième
mais déjà la seconde c'est quelque chose
c'est menaçante une épée de damoclès sur
la tête tout le temps non n'a pas toi en
exode vers ça il a une pointe tactique
qui fait que tu complètement raide c'est
affreux mais c'est vraiment pas de bol
à noter un et dyala gagner aujourd'hui
en national
non mais c'est ça c'est que il avait une
pointe avec du foot pro b ça tue pas sûr
qu'il ait vu lui-même c'est vraiment pas
de chance
104 allez quoi dépasser la centaine
voilà on se bat à fond bon moi je monte
mon roi songez pas mal de matériel
je me bats avec mauroy
allez je repars avec moi de gérer mon
roi est allé prendre un fou mouroir par
ce fantastique j'ai un jet à moi c'est
un génie tu as les gratins fou eux deux
avec le roi je suis reparti
tu l'as dans t'es là c'est bon fabuleux
tient enfin bon le farsi la mort si fort
si ces spécialités niçoises le farci au
lit avec des tomates là bas en fait tu
peux le faire avec les poivrons avec des
tomates avec des courgettes en fait le
farsi va c'est la farce en fait inquiet
dans le dans le dégoût mais allez
bouffer à bouge je balance une classe en
effet cette voie si comme dans la vision
qu'on ait le temps des pompes
ouais chauffage chocolat bon c'était
vraiment de la merde ce que j'ai fait
mais je me sens qu en ligne demain à
nantes j'ai largué un pion au centre
qu'est-ce que je suis nul me demande
pourquoi ne sut pas d'âge wen question
mais en fait à la base bon ok dire je
crois qu'ils ont nationale et cette
année j'aurais été qualifiée pour
l'accession mais je suis pas trop le
savoir à l'avancé conjoint sympathique
puisque trois joueurs invités
c'est un routier je m'inscrirai dépenser
de l'argent mais à des gens attendent en
leur payant alors je suis pro c'est pas
trop mon pied et euh bah du coup j'ai
fait mon planning avant de savoir et bah
c'est chaud aux états unis donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai joué un tournoi juste
avant à washington l'histoire tous un
peu et puis testé le choix des emprunts
de vidéos là dessus pour revenir sur le
tournoi l'ambiance le niveau ça ben
stassen
c'est nouveau ça c'est tatort à dire et
quoi d'autre et puis l'art et chant
choral milliard du coup je passe après
les vacances je découvre je t'ai jamais
venu après qu est ce un peu long je
prends la rentrée ça ira elle mais quand
même
j'attends cette chaîne pour les voir le
messin planois de tennis et je rentre le
31 voilà a donné raison cossu page mais
je râle afin de ramener à 10 ans je suis
pas très content de la formule actuelle
avec seulement dix joueurs de la
nationale alors qu'avant ils allaient 12
est en fait tu vas tu as plus en plus de
joueurs qui sont extraits france est
actuellement plus saintes à 26 jeu
marquant plus de 1500 euros
et puis en fait tu baisse le nombre
d'invités et le nombre de joueurs
invités sur son international puisqu'on
a pu disent qu'en l'accession olympique
3 les temps sont durs pour les finances
fabien barcella reportages et encore on
parle on parle et je vais la transtu
absent m en plus si tu fais que ne
feront que le onze qu'il reste une part
de lazard pas dire muayad ronde - c'est
le meilleur objectivement si calme si tu
fais un trois sur cinq parties dures des
accidents des trucs vraiment s'étonne
n'y a que des nues le béret mais si tu
perds une partie sur un de france
c'est hyper grave qu'en fait face à
étudier au titre donc donc savez pas
quoi faire ce soit d'autre ce stade je
peux aussi faire un gros open 2004 100
par exemple je sais pas un ton plein
d'idées que je trouverai pas mal de
cette recherche spectacle aussi faire 4
couler les premiers sketchs i pod demi
finales et finales où tout coule d'état
des trucs possibles et là en fait tu
vois la nationale battant à reste fort
mais en même temps tu as même plus les
meilleurs qui fera déjà une belle de
jour plus jamais etienne l'an dernier ne
jouait pas et de trois ans ferait ce
n'est pas joué non plus parce qu'il ya
un stage avec magnus et talita parcours
main non plus donc quatre ans n'a plus
vraiment les meilleurs depuis dix
joueurs enfin tout ça ça me ok ça m'a
jeté caddies et je dirais le jouer quoi
mais je veux dire stop
c'est qu'il ya plus de joueurs ici un
depuis que le joueur amateur qui peuvent
venir le vin belize ont réduit la durée
des temps à ça si je suis d'accord en
fait les amateurs mais nous on n'est pas
un matin
on sait le tournoi quatre jours avant
tout ça non mais jusqu'à le dit je crois
qu'ils font ça tournoi le a pas le
principal où tu as pu tâter les petits
tournois aussi à warsage organise pas
mais ça me semble pas impossible à gérer
avant amiens sur deux jours non mais il
ya de moins en moins d'argent dans les
échecs en france nos quais vallière gens
ne lisent pas alors j'aime écouter des
difficultés mais après il ya aussi des
idées jouable quoi à voir mais mais je
décide pas messi rentre donc voilà
pourquoi je ne joue pas et après bas
pour sinon après oui enfin jour est en
france à sochaux façon touristes quoi je
ne sais pas c'est que j'analyse ans si
je suis de touristes suisses des trucs à
d'ailleurs baba ladde tellement j'ai mal
aux jambes aujourd'hui le mandat des
stries milliards aujourd'hui n'est pas
un peu plus calme mais je dois partir
d'ailleurs ce soir je vais voir un de
nos auditeurs s'est tenue hier contacté
sur facebook ou par dans quelques heures
ce n'est pas possible je souffre un fab
la mêlée au père est un parlement qui en
perd et c'est plutôt moi [ __ ] c'est
pas possible de donner une pièce en un
coup comme ça mais c'est pas possible
d'être aussi abrutis assez pénible quand
c'est comme ça c'est tellement dur
moi je pense que tu sais comment c'est
comme ça ne marche plus à quand ça
marche pas c'est dur mais bon a encore
une kalach donne je donne carrément
trois pièces une tour mais bon ça a déjà
commencé le deuxième coup bon allez à
temps faibles mais t'inquiète je vais
réussir à le dominer un jeu je vais
revenir c'est il faut que je prenne ma
forme je touche donc gurry ouais mais
pas facile parfois quand tu es beaucoup
de commentaires beaucoup de trucs tu
vois tu perds un peu le le jeu quoi et
par vote c'est que ça me prend même se
passe par une fois j'ai dû faire une
session de tête 10 heures en ramant
comme ça et le lendemain j'ai bien joué
mais ça c'est une des recettes de vlad
en fait quand tu joues mal et qui doit
reprendre la formule a déjà souvent dit
ça il m'a dit le mieux c'est de jouer
une fois longtemps même s'ils jouent mal
en fait mais longtemps et jean rémy
après à force ça revient tout seul le
lendemain généralement il est le jour où
tu joues longtemps tu reprends pas et le
lendemain tu as eu tu rajoutes bien
normalement ok c'est valve il a la
recette ne lui a toujours aimé les
préparer cette tournée mais l'enjeu
beaucoup jarre je suis un type de jeu
avec vos l'équipe de france nouvelle me
dit le jeu se préparer à vue le cap
d'agde où il est variable mais après je
t'aide europe là où c'est important de
rester là
non mais c'est une technique connue en
fait d'après ce que j'ai compris de
beaucoup jouer pour récupérer la forme
la main je fais maths et en a beaucoup
joué en live un rapport en question doit
jouer en live ou en live celui sur
internet j'ai beaucoup ri sur internet
parce que tu ça dépend où tu dois où tu
dois le faire mais là c'est la cata je
pense qu'ils se foutent de ma gueule sur
le tchat
parfois c'est dur ceux des amis non ça
va leur manquer une nombre de trucs
alors iannuzzo journée après ce trafic
vous allez suivre
caruana ou serbe n'a pas commenté parce
que cet art est ce que nous on va le
suivre personnellement ben écoute je ne
sais pas maintenant un peu d'aliments
les enjeux les rejoindre un auditeur
après moi c'est des heures normales tu
as faim de kate joie par des disques à
3h du mat pour garder sa fonctionne en
mai un mois peut-être j'ai ça ça va
dépendre de sa soirée suivante si je
fais autre chose
là je sais pas pour l'instant mais
pourquoi pas et ce pratiquement dans ton
genre trop ce que tu gagnes viata vivre
ça dépend des performances
bah ça dépend des performances du coup
après j'essaye de faire des trucs à côté
vous donnez un peu des cours d'ailleurs
niveau cours qui avaient moins d'en bas
donc c'est ça peut être assez fou ici
présents de gens connaissent et ont
comme toujours nous contacter je bats
j'ai déjà écrit deux livres j'ai fait
j'ai fait des dvd qui sont pas sortis de
chez spies ont donc un autre sur la
française mon nom courbe emprunte déjà
fait une dizaine d'heures dessus
il en reste encore faire des 31 tours je
le fais quoi d'autre en fait il y as
tout le temps donc mais c'était je suis
les aimants tout ça donc
donc voilà on fait tout ça après ben on
aimerait bien avec la chaîne bien bien
gagné jean après le seul truc délicat ce
qui a marché ce comme personne ne nous a
dit m en effet en appliquant
continuellement sur le jazz gens se
plaindre c'est juste on parle d'une
vérité donc c'est pas forcément évident
si des objections fait lécher la chaîne
youtube l'ont fait tous battu en
retraite en est on n'est pas payé pour
ça donc c'est toujours agréable quand on
reçoit des petits bijoux c'est super
sympa trop tard et après bah du coup en
tant que kruska pour gagner ta vie c'est
pas mal si ces neiges par équipes la tp
donc j'ai pour grasse en france
j'aime qui club espagnol je pas ce genre
tranche avec vingt éléments écrits on
verra l'an prochain en belgique et en
angleterre après je joue pas tous les
matchs non plus par ci par là en
allemagne mais en offrant des joueurs
pros ce n'est pas dans l'élite faut te
battre est-ce qu'on est les sétois des
trucs à droite à gauche s'est jamais
rengard anti régime et de salaire jamais
de contrat comme ça
écoutez désagréable après le match et
que tu voyages des choses comme ça aussi
mais ouais ça serait possible de gagner
plus et de manière plus sûre ça serait
pas une peluche je suis tranquille
voilà alors si non mais tu souffres ou
matsu nuance mobile 6 de game of thrones
baril on a vu après celle pas seulement
parler ici de ce qui je pense est dans
le conte est pas violente appelé spoiler
mais c'est un vrai que jamais enfin vu
que je fais que perdre j'étais obligé de
sortir de la ruine après ouverture
interdit parce que bon j'ai peur face
ban du site ou deux on dénoncera pas
j'espère parce que là je suis en train
de faire la rizza devenue différente une
chaîne youtube d'échec française bah
disons oui tu sais pas un sujet qui
passionne les foules pas mais après pour
les échecs c'est pas mal je trouve un
des audiences qui vialade qui viennent
c'est quand même c'est pas rien je sais
pas si on se rencontre on avait le mec
était dans le top 20 mondial champion
devra passer le plus gros palmarès et à
des échecs français
sinon il est souvent gris le choc sa
défaveur et puis reconnu mondialement
donc c'est cool d'avoir ça avec une une
honte et sa partie kf qui se bat font
bon moi j'essaie d'être la tranche peu
nombreux avaient un niveau et chaque
c'est bien après ouais je compare avec
d'autres chaînes youtube
guy pabois de bonnes choses c'est
différent mais c'est dur parce qu'ils
étaient des chats pour ça que des fois
on a ce tour un peu décalé bas ok c'est
le change un peu ça parce que si on fait
que par l'échec de variantes en fait ça
ne va pas grâce à 100 du par vidéo
on fait ce qu'on peut écouter le mec là
il m'avait battu 5-0 je prends une
partie avec la russie ce bar et se casse
çà tardy gros pâté pas été bonne et dit
non le mek triche jouer tu as ça
horrible ça horrible
surtout que j'ai du mal un jeu souffre
pour pour gagner des parties jouées je
suis retombé en dessous de 2005 et où je
souffre je me bats je gagne une partie
qu avec les tripes et le mec s'en va qu
il comprend que dangereux j'ai pris du
temps il fallait prendre une tôle héros
ouais c'est horrible il ou non votre
chaîne est génial non je vois bien après
voilà ce truc dover fasse pas de choses
à côté et les tournois il n'ya de
chanter transilien
il y a des crampes sturia payer le
punching bag sur l'as monaco est en fait
pour tout événement comme ça fait de
l'argent et tu peux non mais c'est vrai
que ça faisait bizarre fin c'est assez
frustrant d'un point de vue quand tu
fais une chaîne non non ne va pas mais
je veux jamais stressé les gens parce
que j'ai peur qu'il est qu'ils prennent
ça quand on parle comme ça qu'ils
pensent qu'on va arrêter ou quoi c'est
pas du tout le cas en fait on voit les
noms sont souvent on the block bon sens
et ça on sera toujours là mais enfin
toujours juste pas si on sera toujours
là parce qu'enfin on a eu aussi une
feinte physique qui peut arriver à tout
moment quoi mais enfin on n'a pas
l'intention de partir mais c'est vrai
que c'est un peu frustrant quand tu
quand tu vois qu'il ya des événements
donnent du tango où tu peux où tu peux
gagner de l'argent et tout ça est en
fait même si tu fais les meilleures
audiences de juin qui sont vus dix fois
moins que toi en fait quand ils font des
vidéos donc fait tu te demandes fin tu
te demande pas pourquoi on invoquait
mais tu sais pourquoi face et c'est
comme ça mais mais je dis ce serait une
juste récompense que pour le temps passé
pour le développement des jeunes parce
que bon c'est souvent quand il ya des
gens qui est assez cool machin j'ai eu
des chèques ou des vidéos machin on a
l'impression qu'on essaye de faire
avancer fin de mois le partage et la
notion moins bonne humeur pour ça le
juste dommage que jamais être récompensé
en espoirs a sonné mais quelque part
c'est même quelqu'un quelque part même
enfin pas tant mieux dans le sens pas
tant mieux mais dans le sens
les levés on espère non mais enfin dans
un monde normal avec l'égalité des
chances ça aurait payé depuis longtemps
mais bon malheureusement j'ai encore me
faire mater c'est pas possible c'est
horrible c'est horrible c'est le
festival quoi du coup on est quand même
très content de faire de ce pitch est
filmé en et répondant que tu as fait ça
les patchs à ce point comme vraiment y
aurait peut-être plus les vidéos déjà ça
c'est vrai comme on le dit on le dit
souvent mais c'est parce que c'est
vraiment le cas en fait j'espère comme
c'est vraiment les seuls qui nous
adresser les seuls qui sont frères en
fait c'est les seuls qui regarde les
audiences que tu fait qu'ils avaient
tient lui les meilleurs effets des
meilleures audiences ces vidéos doivent
être mieux on va le prendre ils disent
pas à ces ennuis on le connaît donc ça
vraiment c'est top de leur part voilà à
prendre il pour les autres c'est tout ça
qu'on a toujours sur ce point comme on
rend la pièce aussi
donnant donnant je me suis sorti et
doigts du cul pour la gagne et ça les
gens peu plus quoi bouder qu'acheter
cage faasalele ses plaisirs scandinave
damas 5b quatre cavaliers de 6 kg on
prend à 5 dégage damier californie se
prend tous les coups du tennis
l'armée ok mais joli du téléphone
oui mais je suis 10 mètres derrière la
ligne de fond pour lui et je renvoie des
balles en cloche je fais ce que je peux
tu vois la sortie du monde des clubs
c'est ce à quoi je repars en courant je
remets une balle haute le mec ce match
je suis dans les bâches tu vois je mais
là ça là je devais la perdre et
finalement tu vois j'ai réussi à faire
un passing du bout du monde
l'accueil reçu ses amis un califat sur
le chat je suis obligée d'assurer quoi
wiz khalifa mais ce lycée wiz khalifa
regarde attendu qu'on s'en fout à
l'église doit toujours être notre blague
en fait dès qu'ils passent on mène on
pourrait lui écrire lui demander si elle
joue aux échecs fait des vidéos avec la
boum je prends ta zik après nv elle en
fait les mecs vont là ils vont donc
passer au niveau 6 plus beau palmarès
des échecs là quatre chefs non dégage
c'est fini tu ne nous intéresse pas on
ne fait plus de vidéos avec toi même des
gens beaucoup plus qualifiés
il serait bon de commenter une nationale
en même temps égal sa fantastique en top
très intéressant l'histoire que je vais
vous auriez 54 un minimum je pense mais
je pense beaucoup plus en fait
alors
bon j'aurais bien avoir une partie là
les mecs jouent plus les mecs consenti
tu vois là je suis sur trois victoires
d'affilée femme là je suis je suis sur
un rush et a plus personne qui se montre
dangereux ici centaines mais mais c'est
horrible que j'ai un fond noir le
cerveau outil qui pourtant j'ai bien
dormi et tout mais je pense que la
semaine dernière de temps mais je pense
que la semaine dernière des districts
garissa même bien achevée en fait il a
juste sait-on que notre mouvement à tan
tan tan tan tan j'ai plein de trucs
ouverts en même temps aller lyon le
défonce allez les mecs allez on se
chauffe là ça va on arrête de
pleurnicher
on se chauffe la lefp ravatel là je vais
lui le déboîter quoi à chabot qui me
demandent de les commenter sur la
torture dans laquelle un homme du match
de ce soir
donc ça non mais décision d'être une
autre partie de l'antenne du bien et je
le défonce la fac je le prends je le
retourne fraval devons tourner trois
boules dégage
je fais des trucs un peu risqué jeu je
me fait confiance je laisse je laisse
des trucs me fait confiance alors on va
se faire confiance
k&b quintal on se fait confiance à fond
n'a pas peur de rentrer en les tactiques
fab le nom de peur
on lui fait mal la favec tous avec tous
nos coups on lui fait mal il a mal et
allez ça y est ils trouvent des deux dd
des ressources dynamiques c'est pas
croyable ils ont toujours une ressource
un sacrifice qui marche un truc ça va on
tient pour le moment fab
il joue pas mal hein y'a que les lots de
1399 ambulante mais c'est pas un métier
c'est c'est le truc quand je la ressens
c'est la même chose au poker c'est la
même chose dans tous en fait t'es pas en
forme et les mecs sont des génies en
face bout matin de nantes
mais ça va lâcher il va repousser
d'hermann de prévenir le monde
c'est pour nous jeunes au sport bas
quelque part oui pas mais quelque part
nous aussi voyez il ya la dimension
sportive basket a envie d'être sportif
en fait c'est pas mal comme ça je pense
que si tu demandes d'amm et à la
dimension de son corps dans le sens de
compétition ou de choses comme ça quoi
impressionner par la notion pas se situe
par la louis picamoles le je suis pas
sûr que picamoles tu vois ils te disent
des échecs c'est un sport oui parce
qu'il a plus raison que moi je sais pas
s'il a plus eu raison que toi mais vu
que vu qu'il peut soulever 140 kg à la
fonte même si c'est toi qui as raison il
va avoir raison quand même au final il à
dire à moi je dis non je dirais même me
fixe un sport à mieux dire non c'est
c'est un jeu non mais ok vas là-bas
c'était ça comme un jeu mais quand tu
jouais journée douce à côté sport enfin
attend un geste à washington
c'est une dimension physique aussi il ya
ce côté là comme
j'étais loin de me lever et quand tu
pourras jouer en tournoi
la pression du résultat machin ça
dépasse le cadre du jeu à la con il ya
with à nos cousins 2 milliards du cou
qui nous dit ce que prague avait enfin
double amende énorme n 5 ou contraignent
un genre tout à des mots assez normal
oui et non si c'était sa prépa ticket
sait tout faire
j'ai pas vu la partie donc on fatigue et
de l'ariège pas de donner mon avis
dessus
non mais nous ne partons pas en des
histoires que le mec a peut-être touché
ou pas parce que y'a un truc qui m'a
factions armées non non je te le dis pas
non parce que j'ai reçu un message en
abonnés a pas longtemps j'ai rien contre
la bonne odeur qui m'a exclu en question
a mais c'est juste pour parler du du
sentiment de doute kia qui m'écrivait la
partie christian bauer est très étrange
leader du du d'une affaire j'ai
l'impression qu'ils trichent pas juste
ya beaucoup trop de suspicions
maintenant ouais mais je veux dire par
là tu es avec les ordi avec tout ça est
tellement de suspicion maintenant non
mais faut arrêter de voir la triche par
tous les gars vont passer c'est vrai que
ça existe il ya eu des l'histoire mais
ça reste marginal quoi voilà c'est ça si
je me détends parano fait autre chose ça
c'est que ça reste très rare en fait
enfin la plupart des cas c'est juste de
la parano et c'est juste les gens qui
s'invente des histoires
moi je vois la musique qui dit oui non
mais c'est juste que ça me fait penser à
sare de la gagner en tempo c'est de
trouver la partie comme genevoise
connexion internet
elle marche bien je passais nordiques et
décodeurs s'il y avait une solution je
sais pas jusqu'a pas dramatique mais
skype qui marche pas mal ou que je peux
parler kevin de charges une barge
internet mais même un site très ya rien
de support des pages de pas trop
charlène envoyé un message pour une et
fight importe ils demandent si tu
triches en bullet mais il est joyeux
[Musique]
l'échec est là logiciels poursuit chez
les ménages ne triche pas mais en fait
ça se verrait sur l'écran r scores
logiciels en fait ils te montre le coup
ouais en fait il ya une sorte de petite
souris
s'ajoute à ce relais de base il te
montre quoi faire bon bah tu suis la
souris et puis voilà
l'action de vu mon niveau de jeu non
mais tu es très bien fait exprès peur
pour avis a été intelligent riche
intelligente
alors j'aurai déjà partie de prague la
nasa hd trouver sur votre tablette alors
je vais vous dire c'est à dire une taxe
communale qui a trafiqué tout version
maclean's et c'est irréfutable mesquin
et la dame des systèmes saas et les
nouveaux qui font ça
comment on sait on a vu des vidéos sur
youtube ou sur facebook en fait
alors les mecs sur youtube qui fait une
vidéo effets vidéo montrant qu'on y fait
soit ces suppliciés vu ça sur youtube
sur facebook je puisse et la vod sur
l'un ou sur l'autre
mais bon je pense qu'il ya plein
d'autres moyens de faire et du coup par
yona vraiment le tempo que vous êtes
j'ai pas d'apprendre je juge veut la
partie un peu donné vraiment des
français alors où est la nouveauté je
sais pas si les autres s'en va te mettre
entre nous deux communes on veut
l'ouverture est déjà presque 4 cd jared
pressé sco pas si vous y êtes non partie
assez impressionnante alors je sais pas
il connaissait la presse est possible
enfin j'étais pêcheur écrasante et j'ai
la confiance tu finis il a traduit en 15
minutes
moi j'aurais pris beaucoup plus de temps
même des projets parce que j'ai pas une
confiance mais c'est pas faisable
t'as pas le même âge aussi nom et
l'histoire quoi je quitte mon cpu
l'autrichien lie pas vrai c'est arrivé
les tonga sont fait choper sans qu'un
dispositif dans les chiottes soi est une
histoire à l'équateur entre entre les
genres france à tout ça pour vous parmi
ces noms mais c'est déplorable coiffant
monsieur tu d'écouté que ça arrive il
faut pas croire non plus tout le temps
jara je croyais qu'on n'ait jamais
tricher contre moi par exemple j'ai
cannes jouer des milliers de parties
quoi donc c'est pas non plus le truc qui
a tous les jours car si ça arrive si le
soleil carreaux d'état j'espère
connaître un chopper il sera suspendu et
tout ça après sur internet c'est
effectivement ça peut arriver longtemps
son flottement de creston internet c'est
juste massimi cairote tricher en face et
c'est une façon très choisis moi où tu
vas tu vas parlant batterie basse terre
c'est officieux battu quel miracle à ça
donc les gens trichent interne pas
qu'ils trichent avec lui je m'en fous et
voilà c'est plus simple
c'est horrible ce que je viens de rater
c'est une honte c'est une honte
c'est honteux d'être aussi nul c'est
honteux a dit riesch à sebha manon
article parle pas juste ok après quand
aller vite un soupçon en fait le mec à
15 cents qui a eu comme boris ivanov par
le bulgare gpat et demi qui d'un coup de
défonce tous les grands maîtres fini
c'est pas nous c'est les 13 ans et que
tu dis [ __ ] il est jeune il progresse
peut-être par manque m donc il n'ya pas
de raison que d'un quizz vente imaginer
quoi tu à progresser bien sûr mais tu as
deux pattes 2000 à 2008 et auraient le
même juste passer tout le monde quoi ils
disaient les parties en plus ou même
quand il était beaucoup mieux il
continue des coûts complètement dans des
gens fument castro formes prises
imprenable machin ok quoi mais là en
fait juste et flamands quoi donc voilà
un jour un jour il nous demandait comme
un trophée une flux si les gars je
m'écarte d'être fouillés il file à
accepter quand même d'ailleurs d'être
fouillée de la fois où j'ai pas quoi
mais là bizarrement ils n'étaient pas
contents mais en fait apparemment ils
vendent sous les chaussures ce qui en
fait la faudra refuser c'est quand
ok ils ont tâté le corps machin mais il
n'a rien fait et chaussures et a dit non
mais pourquoi je sens je sent mauvais
défier le nom n'a pas marché sur vire et
du temps soit mais ça c'est un régal
grotesque mais bon c'était le truc assez
au vieux ça oui mais après le seul truc
c'est que si quelqu'un le fait
intelligemment c'est pas du genre à
nantes a dit si je pouvais demander un
coût par partie mais même pas demandé le
coup on va demander l'évaluation une
fois par un escalier en fer toi tu es
une position ou [ __ ] tu sens qu'il ya
un truc débat sur john o'neill mais
s'est dit très difficile d'évaluer les
conséquences
ok c'est un droit d'avoir un joker
l'élection c'est quoi les mecs te
dépasser puis 150 battu petit sur sa
bonne idée étudiant qui avait géré
[ __ ] tu peux jouer il dit ok ces
mignonnes je gagne 7 points l'ol
donc ils pensent 28 50 ans voit
justement d'animation une fois c'est une
barque pendant un coût mondial
mais nombreux à vouloir promo sera super
marginal faut pas sans mal avec ça
suzanne viennent soit payé sous forme on
s'en fout car changer d'adversaire
c'est pas la fin du monde quoi sur
internet et obtient avec un buzz sur
internet
qu'est ce que ça change je m'en fous du
vélo à 2007 à 2101 2004 d'une ceinture
sur internet
fight om-bordeaux dit on dit jeu super
bitz a chassé tous les tricheurs de
plaine dont futur est ce vrai en fait
non mais en fait super beast a déjà dit
enfin que moi qui le connais un peu
mieux que tu me l'as sur le chat room
sont comme vous connaissez pas trop plu
personnes jouent aux échecs dans le
futur en fait c'est saisonniers marginal
à force de faire n'importe quoi
plus personne ne joue en fait donc fait
quelques paris se sont tassés de manioc
la dernière génération ce the way
mais en fait c'est ouais suite suite à
un nombre d'erreurs incalculable gerra
force d'organiser n'importe quoi en fait
personne ne joue en fait les aubrac 33
taudis connaissent là je suis aussi des
outils une onde un voyant de feu c'est
chez leur vie c'était après avoir la
redif quelques parts et sur les chaînes
ça va être horrible et ouais je sais pas
quand il met le règlement c'est un bon
match du goût de dix paquets gagner du
coup on ne trouve pas eu là pas comme
les vostro newspaper
je suis passé au magasin bio est en fait
il pas très gros projet peut-être ont
des souvenirs game of thrones ou pas
bien trouver de l'aide et magnifique
statue est offert aux attentes des
objets soumis au queen mary et à y ait
une étude des risques 3e
moment je devrais dragon qui crache face
à neuf
je peux trouver des oeufs de poule aussi
peux vous dire c'est dragon où je les
vois la bassée milliards d'eur aussi
dans la vraie vie daenerys d2 elle est
brune nombre ouais c'est hyper laborieux
fabien je te passe les détails des
parties le tout à l'heure parce que
c'est j'ai l'impression que c'est
c'était le 25 28 je suis en train en
pleine remonte à damer fin je je je je
fais de la merde mais total je vois
absolument rien j'ai l'impression d'être
en pls constante en fait alors qu'elles
gagnent des finales en fait bon je vous
défie de change de fun board la retrouve
la rediff de switcher pâtes bio
ingénierie et wiz khalifa dit quoi si je
lance un projet chez oscar washington
chances de personnes j'ai pas compris
il veut laver les bagnoles en jouant aux
échecs
mis à part le mec veut faire nul la fin
j'ai enfin c'est très fatigant mr quoi
je pensais bonnes choses boxing bas
parce que justement très propre à sa
super au sérieux c'est fun quoi voilà la
seule côte est j'avoue que c'est quand
même beaucoup plus important d'être
exposé chats archéo-québec j'étais
vraiment du lot d'échecs au pire tu
perds pas au premier round alors tu
penses que tu planes tu fais aussi des
sites une risques tu feras pas maté
virtualité les matières afc a traité
limitant intimité pièce
ok tu as deux premiers volets mais bon
tu as été un premier run facile deuxième
ha oui tiens bon de ne pas tenter pas
mal
par contre si kessy à la boxe est un
tueur
j'ai en moi mais avec vraiment nul aux
échecs mais qui sait boxer et comme le
tien vous avez fait que le super bien
mais bon j'ai pas encore arrêté et là
on ne vote pas être un peu prétentieux
terme comme feu maintenant mais faut
avoir un certain niveau à la boxe à la
wii mais sa légère initiation j'ai déjà
réussi ce que ça ajoute t il nous
regarde pas améliorer son français est
mon jeu en même temps alors français on
n'est pas sûr d'être parents parlent pas
un gage toujours châtié de france à des
livres français du molière ou parlant de
visites des fromages nos gouvernants et
addictions d'ailleurs stress quand ces
nouveaux modes de diction mais je sais
je me fixe ou encore gagné mais c'est
hyper laborieux je pense que les gens
peuvent te raconter dans le tchat
c'est vraiment de la merde ce que je
fais est ce que c'est c'est affreux
c'est affligeant bon nul
c'est difficile de moins bien jouer aux
échecs je suis pas si des gens ont
réussi mais mais ce qui est sûr c'est
que sa demande
ça demande du travail de mon avenir je
crois la miss tourcoing sinon on renonce
pour venus en bateau truc au jazz boxing
gambadent en france soit que meilleure
je pense c'est karl semaines donc il a
la trempe par 35 ans il est aux échecs
il entre 2002-2003 parce qu'il a passé à
mano entre les deux jeux touba mal aux
échecs et la boxe à la base y pense même
pas trop femme il s'est entraîné en fait
il est au club tous les jours on a beau
faire les exercices machin et donc il
induit les retards peuvent même à la
boxe c'est pas mal voilà un boxer de
métier de masse
donc ça c'est niveau pas de champion de
france achètent pas nouveau non serait
je raconte la vie dure et si tu te fais
défoncer la boxe en plus je crois plus
je ne suis pas ok ça je pense remparts
terrebonne est ce qu'ils avaient fait il
ne propose qu'un seul spectateur ne
regardes tu es parti matches j'espère
parce que c'est vers 7h à double salchow
c'est le chercheur qui demandent si noël
voici ses cibles pour les gones 2006 et
entre larmes et là bas des gens mais je
sais pas si mal kaki et réunis au stade
- 2004 voilà annoncé ardemment pour
l'avoir lucerne ce qu'il ya des
champions du monde ils 23,50 l'église en
réserve en boxe ouais mais ça fait mal
aux échecs tomba après un mort il tombe
sur un autre boxeur je pense quelque
part n'at-il pas mal 23 50 dates à
retenir contre les bots c'était vraiment
qui défonce tient aux échecs mais du
coup ne crois pas que cette saison
dernière qu'on se croit il ya des
marrants s'effacer pour le choucas ou
que dehors du public trucks sas il ya
plus de public chessboxing peser chacun
à gimeaux d'événements payent leur place
aux échecs tu as moins de monde et c'est
gratuit
singh de réussir l'exploit d'être moins
populaire qu'un sport annexe de ton
sport en fait c'est pas si ça existe en
deux espoirs en fait que tendue soit
tellement il est intéressant de la
pendule commencé à organiser que même un
truc annexes qui devrait être genre
vraiment un truc marginal soit plus
intéressante contre eu qu'en fait c'est
peut-être un cas unique en fête sans
musique
c'est unique et c'est fantastique en
fait on vient de découvrir un truc les
mecs on est on est sur quelque chose là
d'ailleurs samedi
samedi saint au dimanche soir mcgregor
machin j'ai regardé c'est dans un bar ça
veut dire quoi en france sas atteint 3 3
heures du matin du match
tariq teguia grâce à des fonds non mais
je me connais pas trop en boxe je peux
pas te je suis encore fait avoir comme
un bleu
avez vous eu cinq échecs mais yes yes
fabuleux pas vraiment comme un comme un
lion quoi sur un char lan mister theron
sa mère tu vas faire tomber l'abruti je
suis socialiste et repas chez yes
comment je pressenti pour la prochaine
saison de game of thrones quoi saison 8
j'arrive je défonce et walker soit boom
show américain ajoute que des finales en
plus c'est fantastique
le mec t'as pas compris la finesse est
toujours là je me sens pls la question
je suis le chemin la tempête et vous tu
veux
ça parle de mode sur le chat ça par le
patronat mais wever belge venait
apparemment j'éprouve favoris les grands
favoris
rendez vous la nouvelle aux 25 38 mais
c'est déjà un exploit
je vais aller voir nos stades de l'open
c'est genève qui joue pas mal de dents
il à combien de points il y avait cinq
romy les quatre années sur cinq est plus
tout seul peut êre 20 ans
ça ne la gagnera pas mais ok on 6 il a
fait nul c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
il y là c'est bien ça quand on dit du
coup je la perds c'est horrible ça on
est retombé fabien une finale que
j'aurais jamais dû perdre mais il m'a
fait et non mais ok et l'accession il ya
barbeau qui caracole que d'un point
d'avancé mais reste à trois rondes
il a déjà joué contre billet il a déjà
joué contre jean marc et a déjà joué
tout jean-pierre donc barbeau menaçant
dans la qualif au national il peut le
faire un beau menaçants après quatre et
demi et une flopée d bilel il ya jean
marc et jean pierre vidal psl de grêle
donc amour quand un oiseau diam's il
était de faire son apparition alors
qu'il était toujours une partie après et
pas sur lui même qui c'est là sur 3 où
tout peut arriver et ok ok ok c'est un
joli si mal j'y arriverai pas je n'y
arriverai pas pas aujourd'hui en tout
cas peut-être demain et après demain on
essaye déjà 25 50 pc totalement déjà
marais mais j'avais déjà du mal ça
traîne là je sens que ça je mette mes
lunettes en fait foi sa mère
sur le chat se dise quoi il fasse
marrant si vous tes ma gueule non pas de
sa compagne du tout le principe
chessboxing je vais vous découvrir le
principe c'est que votre mélange de
sport de base dans leur ensemble le
d'échecs avec tranquille dans
l'imaginaire collectif les échecs se
voit la somme était revenu non c'est
chez pas ces genres le petit pépère qui
chili avec solar cognac il considère les
mutoi made in usa avec la botte
donc c'est en principe ce que tu fais un
clash entre deux mondes différents et
est en gros oui tu commences une partie
d'échecs en fait le combat sera qu'un
chocolat rock ce soit aux échecs et mat
aux échecs donc tu commences je bats
pour ça joue aux échecs mais je ne suis
pas la partie peut-être un quart d'heure
par joueur mais tu fais des rangers
après peut-être cinq minutes d'échec
premier cheval exact puisque hop voilà
premier en déchets de terminer ce qu'il
appelle matt mais on passe à la botte
enfile tes gants et puis qui va pas une
crainte de boxe bon après je passe ou
des ventes de 3 minutes c'est une minute
ou deux ne s'est pas bâtie à peu du
chaos voiture part en échec tu vas voir
c'est le ton est un bon jour si elle
chante pas de match lors par la boxe a
juste été un truc
voilà c'est ça le principe ça s'est fait
en fait non
après il ya d'autres trucs qu'on va les
échecs que george a joué au con djs bon
ça ce n'est pas officiel mais c'est
juste tu gères tu es un échiquier on va
vers la tuque et une table avec la
pendule tu veux ajoutons coutu course la
pendule appuyer l adresse à tous et peut
jouer
une cour il va appuyer puis peut-être
chaque coup du programme être moins au
plus fin que la pendule 8 ou pas cette
grève aussi donc tu peut allier l'échec
a voté un traitement jamais vu trois de
s'améliorer les échecs c'est autre chose
quand même dû prendre le truc fun
j'avais fait un beach est comme ça mais
dans look onu et l autre côté de la
piscine une longue à fans sachent quand
world suf on s'amusait fait ça me crève
pas nager c'est à dire aïe aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
là je m'envoie fond
mais sarko tunis et chauffe voir s'ils
collaborent savez qu'il ya une cure
c'est vrai oui c'était une commotion
cérébrale juge urgent à faire que de
quelques demandes et chacun devant mike
tyson et identité de ruiz je pense il a
réussi très facilement mike tyson à ruiz
c'est aux rounds de boxe sur l'échiquier
2007 pas réputé la richard ouverture
interdite
est-ce que tu prends tu te rend trop de
chaos en fait trop de mecs souffre et
défonçant la joie de leurs vertus a été
interdite se trouvent bons alors à temps
bon ben voila je ne vois rien mais je re
je montre sait pas trop comment je monte
mais je monte
ils se foutent de ma gueule c'est des
amis ça non mais je sens qu'ils se
foutent de ma gueule en fait je le sens
jésus fasse attention quand même parce
que je suis quand même là quoi puisqu'il
fait des deals with two contre des zones
cherche tous les matchs des possibles
pour tenter d'y perdre pas surtout pas
la vôtre c'est pas faux désormais la
salle n'est peut-être pas toujours été
aussi tué sa femme
enfin parmi les problèmes dans la vie
mais j'ai lu son autobiographie je sais
qu'à laisser gruger sa femme raconte en
fait c'est vraiment plus du kevin voilà
c'est ça mon père ça ne me disait rien
mais on la tue la charge non mais déjà
russe au sein de biographies bon tu vois
c'est à dire un peu galère cmh à 1,5 et
qui dit ok après qu'un très content
qu'il ait une nouvelle vie à une
deuxième vie c'est calme il a présenté
les batteries machar il dotera
reconnaissant d'ailleurs on à sky italia
faucher salaire promis sur le game on va
dire oui à mont-joli karabakh et satar
95 soyez plus de bateaux que son passé
était mon chouchou et puis il me dit qu
il était prêt ni coup bas
salé sous les jeux c'est pas un con tu
régime une station comme ça a peut-être
fait massacrer il attractif
ça c'est pas trop où je peux vous dire
ça chic type non plus quoi là et une
vendue taille âgées la maintenance chez
moi c'est un très beau et bon c'est
intéressant je sais pas après ski femme
et toi je crois que même quantité de
farine qui fait attendre son quartier de
quand il était jeune il a du cash sur
lui il fait libye ap les gens qui croisa
comme ça toi il ya quelque part sous la
main un truc comme ça
regardez donc x factor mais les plans
ça ils ont tous fait un tous les
rappeurs le fonds a dit qu'un petit bout
de femme barrett là j'ai une tendresse
connexion internet c'est johnny que je
sois là pour parler sais pas ce qui se
passe sur ces marchés très bien mais là
puisqu'il est riche en talent est là ce
dimanche montheysanne langue ospel je
suis allé dimanche dernier une baisse de
gospel c'était cool c'est bon quoi dire
je sais pas peut-être dimanche prochain
giro l'enfant sapa livre que b
l'ambiance gens sont affrontés sans
transporter une belle ambiance à ne pas
avoir bu t khd cage c'est des mecs se
sont battus à une partie d'échecs genre
tu plus chic sénateurs de merde t'as
joue la remise des gaz émis sans la plus
drôle que j'ai vu dans un port à des
chèques mais j'aime pas si je te
rappelle que j'étais là mais c'était là
quand j'ai raconté en fait l'histoire la
plus drôle que j'ai besoin d'avoir des
chèques face il y avait vraiment une
baston n'était pas entre deux joueurs
c'était un joueur s'était autant arcania
longtemps moi je citerai pas le nom du
joueur me faut des raisons claires mais
en fait ils venaient y venaient au parti
avec sa maîtresse en fait et à un moment
donné sa femme qu'il est marc lazar
femme qui débarque et elle a défoncé sa
maîtresse des genres défoncé et du coup
sa faillite
ouais mais c'était gros parce qu'en fait
c'était après le début de la ronde il
n'y avait pas un bruit et là tout d'un
coup est un connard je veux plutôt moi
ça me donnait à cheveux non mais face à
nous olivier bajard diassé depuis deux
parties ont des trucs comme ça va
vraiment passé une histoire et je signe
donc sa chatte vous et non
non non on n'est pas là pour ça on n'est
pas là pour ça mais à nous journalistes
sportifs de dire qu'il fréquenterait le
talking blues ça ne nous regarde pas
mais truc marrant c'est que tous les
jours tous les jours suivant sa femme
était là en fait certains c'est la bonne
chose c'est que c'est qu'en fait il n'a
pas du tout divorce est un fait enfin je
sais pas si a pris la défense après le
tournoi mais en tout cas comme jour même
en tout cas non mais tous les jours
suivants ça va être fou tant la voir les
parties et tu sentais que leur fallait
pas bouger quoi ne te lèves pas dans mes
choix personnes de regarder une toux une
sortie non plus un mec très simple c'est
quelque part ça l'arrangé encore plus
charismatiques cette histoire après ok
je sais pas des faillites pour une
partie on avait parié hier de sa renault
igor van himst est pas qu une partie qui
après dix années après dans les années
80 ch litre
une histoire entre marciano et son ton
roman national je crois enfin je crois
que c'est une ronde ou c'est moi j'étais
pas là gimbert 80 tailler des 90 kw à ce
qu'on m'a raconté c'est que j'arbore les
deux sont tous les saints de glace qui
se connaissent et là il devait l'être
marciano et les blancs sont s'en trouve
comme fort il ya un moment à son trajet
la serbie à la salle du tournoi et
surtout du petit l'art et moi là je vais
acheter des clopes et merci moi ça me
fait chier quoi famille des jeux son
coup quoi il parle tout bas je t'arrête
là le feu est rouge précis dès qu'ils
passent au vert je d'émargement d'un bon
sens du meeting
il descend pas ils nous croient pas trop
bon et se casser la chaîne cyclope pas
le feu passe au vert mais se casse à la
salle du tournoi du coup sans doute ont
ils assez klopp médaillés petite voiture
donc je sais pas s'il va la salle
ducrocq footing mais avec du retard
quand ils arrivent ils n'étaient pas
très contents du coup je sais pas à quel
point ces battues ou quoi mais il ya eu
aussi à pas les histoires un peu marrant
que le valeureux gilles bayard de nom et
qui s'étaient déguisés s'était déguisé
par le national mais on peut dire en
fait ils sont huit sacs contenant 2,6 à
7,6 gothique de l'oiseau le beurre soit
la vidéo sur youtube je pense bernard et
mais il a il avait il avait une
suspension après à cause de ça non mais
c'est pas trop cher ses ordres moi
j'étais là et j'avais même pas remarqué
ça tombe on voit sur la vidéo je suis
car au contraire vu comme ça ça se passe
derrière moi la s'adjuge je remarque
pourtant dans une agitation d'un truc et
j'en garde un texto ce dernier mais une
partie importante si je gagnais je peux
me qualifier
j'avais les normes du bit à fond et à
doc et avant je suis quand même bon coup
et j'ai pas eu le temps de voir la fin
de sa voix qui était monté déguisée sur
la nationale mazeau du grand père il
devait à la base je crois à les
assassins de iosis d'habitants il avait
déjà fait nul est donc égale et ses
soeurs à l'échiquier jouer tout seul des
coûts et bien moment est déclenché à se
parler sexualité ils couraient entre les
tables basses et un panneau portait
comme ça durera longtemps puis 18h55
minutes entre le moment où il arrivait
que sécurité viennent ça régis stars 2
millions 11,5 ans que je prends mes
pattes assez marrant enfin il ya ben non
moi je trouvais ça f1 je trouve génial
ce qu'il a fait c'est fantastique
bien que par c'est un peu comme au foot
les strikes en effet stryker médical
avec qui courent après ouais c'est pas
sérieux sans rien changer le nom
d'athlétisme souvent ça fait partie du
folklore
en tout cas voilà mais qui n'est pas
agréé c'est sûr ça nous vient du
déguisée ce soit une table les
personnages qu'il est on enlève qui
monte en plus c'est pas si grave au plus
les rues les faire nul contre lui aussi
j'avais complètement écrasé le mec en
face éveil il fait une remontée d'un
studio j'ai raté une kalach sur un coût
non en fait j'étais bien non mais
bizarrement
il y avait ces quatre échecs qui gagne
une pièce en un coup mais c'est ouf je
rate un nombre de trucs fab ça affreux
je vois les trucs mais genre avec un peu
de retard à faire foi trotter eu à
chaque fois je les vois en fait les
trucs mince et du coup ça me fait un peu
craqué
comment non mais ça va j'ai fait la
guerre une version complètement raide
mais au moins j'ai flingué par au moins
je fais quelque chose ça fait penser à
mort place ont envahi le lieu sur le
tchat
thibault match nice bat snake cgt c'est
à dire c'était plaisant va pas déranger
j'étais sur scène donc bref suspension
un peu lourdes comme si tu peux faire un
truc pour le syndrome suspendu je ne
sais pas je crois c'est un taux de 6
mois je suis né prime il n'est pas pris
deux ans même n'a peut-être pas pris
deux ans la pression s'est un peu trop
il est pas vu sur scène à casser les
gens ok tu n'as pas que ça arrive tout
le temps non plus et on peut peut être
un peu de gens aussi un peu je fais
n'importe quoi
ça c'est fait
l'armée nous aussi on aime bien ce genre
de phase pour ça on est on est indulgent
parce qu'on aime bien un peu les échecs
surface est tellement non plus il est
arrivé si c'est vraiment le zaï t-notes
s'agit d'un jeu ou pas je ne sais pas
et puis ils inviteraient autorisé de m
stop
peut-être at-elle tant on attendait le
pas donc une pause
layrac en divino de pose en revanche pas
que j'allais enfin senti qu a sonné or
une partie est plutôt d'entendre 4,5 à
lavaur c'est vraiment chiant parce qu'on
a dû évacuer la salle dont on y pose à
la pendue dans ce casse tous dehors des
points à une demi heure je sors tout
vêtement de la partie là pour le coup
d'un parti peut parler que n'importe qui
minutes et on téléphone sur toi voilà
c'était chiant là je pense que l'art
tous les partis à 0 on avait continué en
a trop donc du coup ça c'était beaucoup
plus chiant d'avoir le sens des queues
de thibault qui venait juste rigolé cinq
minutes sur sa nouvelle vers
l'adversaire il a plu à ces deux lots
mais bon on est on est on est bloqué à
25 40 mais c'est pas mal remonte en
dessous des 25 me et le vol des pendus
jalons de réponse à ça me comprend et
pas dire à verser 90
je sais pas c'est ce constat qui a fait
ça sachez que tu dis doute à 177
personnes quand même des 185 mm aussi
dans l'histoire une grève s'était fait
voler sa valise quand j'ai vu des trucs
chiants il ya des trucs mans le thibault
s'est très mal alarme incendie ça c'est
pas de chance c'est chiant pour les
entraîneurs elle évolue formule c'est
déjà la preuve l'épaule c'est vraiment
un truc et il vole une valise aussi ça
c'est les choses le parigot l'ex à 2150
on n'y arrivera pas et 2600 j'aurais
bien aimé faire mais risquent 20 miss
forêts trouver un adversaire plus fort
en fait on a perdu un peu de de temps à
jouer fin de temps à force quand tu
défense devant quelqu'un il a un trop
petit et l'eau après
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que je joue
vraiment mal je sais même pas comment je
suis pour car les 25-50 là c'est honteux
qui bougent les fesses tu bouges mais
aussi de dépasser les 200 ont des 191
commerce de bois ont squatté un centre
de vote en pire brahim parce qu'on est
sûr chat point tv se lâche comme au quai
d'où le rien devant moi le vélo de
plongeurs
on n'imagine pas après jo je sais pas
peut-être attaque et moi-même pour
diffamation montage se serait pas debout
mais ouais mais moche histoire mais
j'aimerais bien rester en 2011 ainsi à
john déjà longtemps fin n'est pas si
évidente
tu parlais l'histoire des vols des
pendules non mais bon elle aussi s'était
fait voler sa valise dans sa chambre
dedans et soir
elles permettent de vol en fait je suis
avait un rapport avec l'oiseau ce sommet
sur de la trouve très sympa quoi
voilà ce que j'avais vu la ville de caen
par contre c'est assez cool quand comme
ville
certains bien fernand raynaud la
toussaint je crois l'aide après deux
mois c'était bien cerner retour et de
nouveaux adversaires là une fois un
nouvel adversaire
allez lire ici on se sent en éloigne qui
joue le dr et une heure mais combien la
00 j'allais voir vous tenir au courant
voilà pressé par un match fantastique
non l'om n'a pas de marge
le titre l'italie mène déjà 2 ans bon ça
qu'on sort demain chez payot je prends
vraiment pourquoi ils disent que c'est
important de celui qui se qualifie mais
bon j'ai jamais j'ai pas trop compris
pourquoi c'est important d'accord de se
qualifier j'ai vu ça un peu cette fois
c'est toujours cool quoi te qualifier
pour une audition après oui mais oui
c'est moins rémunérateurs que la ligue
des champions mais l'effort l'argent moi
j'étais très content que ça faisait
quand on joue chaque année c'était du
banjo de rock marchand cool a compté
compétiteurs en fait depuis des mois je
suis pas le gagner sinon ils vont des
débutants pour voir où on va tableau de
chasse pourquoi masquer plutôt à ces
débutants mais cette montée des réseaux
mal de trucs comme ça il y a j'ai fini
il prend un truc genre chess primard
soviétique sans l'anglais ben spies un
ennui passe tu connais aucun nom
et sinon on a vu le tirage des champions
les clubs français par n'y a pas partout
de plus violent pour paris et lille et
monaco j'ai vu ça va pas mal le tir de
paul fokam fiara je me dis non le mahou
slip quelle horreur
oui une tour une tour en un coup une
position complètement fermée qui était
qui était complètement gagnante en fait
ouais c'est ça en fait un cas douteux
pour donner cette échelle sur la chine
ça marchait pas vous savez comme moi je
vois pas les chignons aucune idée je
sais pas j'en sais rien
ce que je sais c'est que j'étais
vraiment gagnant donc ce que j'ai fait
ça suffisait mais le problème c'est que
heures
à
mais un petit [ __ ] trop grave aïe aïe
aïe les gens prennent d'affichage de
temps aussi du coup je peux pas avoir
mon temps ni le temps de l'adversaire de
faire un refresh on a vraiment tous
contre nous fait ce soir les éléments
sont contre nous j'ai pas trop aimé lui
nettement plus les lunettes jaunes sont
utilisés bleu blanc rouge bleu blanc
rouge lorsque saâdane est gris et bleu
blanc rouge allait pourtant j'ai eu
hélène leblanc roule f qu'on se bat à
fond 1
en fait je vois un peu moins bien c'est
peut-être ça va m'aider en réalité mais
peut-être que ça fatigue - mes yeux
c'est mes yeux sont fatigués et
peut-être pour fait en voyant moins bien
ça va me j'arrive à être plus concentrés
en réalité on va voir ce que ça donne
pour le moment cette partie fab
je me bats je ne dis plus rien non plus
réussi
bref pas que je me fasse mater et dans
ces cas là ça ira mais bon normalement
ya pas de matane ans ça va je n'ai eu de
choc ce matin
non j'ai à lille à une attaque et mais
ça va juste comme ça va ça je me suis
débarrassé de son attaque maintenant
faut que je passe mes pions et ça ira
il n'y a que des randos dans tout le
monde et bg les lunettes
oui ou non si oui fin de la chance ce
soir à la fête caruana s'est pas agi et
ses invendus ou pas mais en partie
rapide c'est moi sa cadence donc à
partir de là il part de chance qu'est-ce
que mignard et d'histoire faire libye
puisque milliard et des chances quand
même une heure des chances il m'a 15h30
hec et obstrue de contact sont pas
spontanément je suis pas trop pâti
grenier à pickering et papy grenier du
coup est ce que tu as regardé le laisse
filer le narratif donc sur sur guide de
guild wars 2 vous guider vous regardez
ça me met très très bien là le let's
play que j'ai regardé tout à leur fusion
au saumon saké l'heure où les fans n'ont
eu aucun échange s'est terminé sa mini
un peu tard si vous les veillées où cet
insomniaque une raison si vous voulez
vous que le regard des juges mais où
courir à pattes mais ici nous sinon il y
aura les commentaires en anglais de
toute façon une toile à me regarder sans
commentaire juste sur le l'interface
thiès comme et appuient leur option
plein d'options
quelle mauvaise les chances du rouleau
quelle mauvaise technique
12h10 du genre serres de france a le
sang chaud
est ce qu'en fait son second un rapport
en fait d'ailleurs plus sérieusement si
les fans heureux
non mais attends ils me proposent leurs
actions de plus je ne fais pas tenu la
fin je joue déjà très mal si je commence
à voir une quand j'ai des pions de plus
respecteux moi mais je comprends qu'il
veuille faire nul mais c'est en train de
te domine et on cavaliers de merde donc
tout cas rien de se faire dominer jon le
défoncer la voilà abandonne ça c'est
bien ça oui je cherche une promo espagne
mais avec un fond de moi non mais
respectivement
à ce qu'on a et ce qu'on a la réponse de
with weezi bien giffen dans cet hominidé
d'absence a donc il est jeune ça veut
dire qu'il doit il a il a pas plus de 25
ans je pense with maximum de noms de
plus de 25 ans nous on peut en fait
sourire même quand notre copine est là
quand on est marié enfin moi en tout cas
je fais ce que tu veux bon alors ce roi
c'est de la merde on va le ramener au
centre à l'est on est très mal on est
très mal on va attaquer comme des
débiles
ok un échec requis mais y'a dangereux
bon ok on va envoyer ça là bas quand
même c'est que trop de matériel la fab
fab j'ai peut-être un perpète
non faut le rendre beau jeu pas de père
pète mais [ __ ] j'ai rien j'ai rien fab
désolé fausse alerte la sauce on va voir
vite imaginé que l'assaut comme
commentaire donc voilà la radio koi
j'espère espère avoir un truc mais en
fait derrière je pense que je faisais je
pense que c'est fini je pense que j'ai
appris un cédric le truc qu'on allait se
tuer
j'ai déjà vu ça avec un élève qui est
qu'à ses débuts temps une finale non non
un truc dans l'ouverture complètement
ridicule tu gagnes une pièce
mais genre super ridicule
parler ils font 1 0 mais j'ai gagné la
pièce la dame mais c'est complètement
finie la fage et j'ai une pièce de plus
en finale pour eux 0 pions je combats le
met quasiment il a échangé tous les
atouts du tout est changé en fait pour
entendre un final depuis avec une pièce
de moi j'ai pas trop compris le concept
mais
alors
bon allez hop gagner à les commandes
mais je passe bloqué vers les 25-50 ça
dit quoi là dans le chat je ne suis plus
le chat a du coup tu ne me fais plus
suivant bas rhin sociale depuis le
dernier truc ça n'a pas trop réagi
ouais ça ne réagit pas une réaction
c'est assez mou c'est assez mou
zack rage a fait changer les dames
dommage dommage dommage enfin j'ai perdu
pas mal de temps à essayer de ne pas me
les faire échanger bon mais je gagne un
pion dans le fait de bandes qui écrit
mes écrits quoi du coup quelques riffs
ait quelque chose d'autre
la mystique mais dix grands dieux des
traitements sais pas trop quoi réponse
parce qu' on est sur le bon stream bas
n'ont pas forcément là
whisky et fendi bas qui est parti ne
vous demandez pas partis sont horribles
1 je l'aï dit mais bon c'est aussi parce
que c'est intéressant et marrant de voir
ce qui se passe n'est pas en forme
ah non je n'arrive pas à ce soir c'est
dur je reste j'ai gagné une partie de
faire une partie et où je sais quand je
suis en forme je vende facile on admire
belge erreur perdu hier orange qui dit
c'est tout a changé en bolton ils sont
tous des cas n -b nice a eu contre lui
mais laïque cette forme là ça être
difficile et après boucas qui le dit et
le boulot difficile à suivre
ouais bon des fois dragon mis un joli
c'est un peu freestyle où on change de
forme à chaque fois celui ci fait que le
chat et quelques jours le temps ils font
tant d'autres choses un defy est un
tournoi ajusté entre les membres
n'oubliez pas de cliquer sur toi sur les
scop c'est gratuit maintenant on veut
faire des comptes prévient me payant
mais ça c'est vous qui voyez vous avez
des options plus c'est complètement
possible mais sinon juste kremlin femmes
ce dont on fête le vendredi passé
interne ne boude pas mixtes rim sur
tandis qu'arles une personne des
discussions voilà si vous voulez y aller
dessus
peut-être copier le lien en tchat
l'histoire et jean benoît marfaing et
sinon le joli chaque régie du mois enfin
on a réussi enfin à taper un mec qui a
un bon classement malheureusement j'ai
déjà fait un mois ou slip d'entrée
mairie qui m'a pas coûté trop cher
allez il faut le farcir fab celui-là
fait encore quelques parcours à faire un
peu de rab pour essayer de finir sur une
bonne note
on va faire ce qu'on peut
ah ouais en faisons pour répondre à cet
homme d'ordre non mais je comprends ce
que tu dis d'après ce que chacun savait
que ces valeurs quoi car il donne au
bord d'un ghat leçons de morale
non mais c'est trop long à lire battu
les salir après le succès comment
participer au tournoi nous l'aurait lien
bien là ce soir on fait pas mais c'est
demain
en fait faut bacri un absolutisme comme
j'ai dit c'est gratuit après si vous
voulez trahir votre truc dans les vidéos
les machins payant c'est quoi ton
possible événement dont l'histoire est
là dessus font rejoindre le club
victimes civiles qui écrit ça et ils
croient d'autres après une fois que tu
es là dessus je prône le tournant c'est
le vendre et c'est quoi ça va 5 matin
c'est à travers cinq batteurs et jeudi
passé ce stream à 15h pas perdre de
temps jeunes consommateurs 30 pc
tournant dans la vie de sainte claire et
puis après ça par contre c'est trop
simple et plus fort
comment alors ici c'est paris c'est pas
gagné qu'une dame de plus chanceux ont
retrouvé une pulsion il a quoi avec une
dame de plus mais ça va je les jeux
l'étape la scoreuse ou contre avec à
2006 du coin avec avec un bonnet lo
peut-être changer grâce à leurs acquis
et complètement je sais pas si on en
gagne trolls qui nous parle de sommes
s'il voit monter assez on va répondre
quand même pas tout à fait complètement
s'approche d'eux mais du coup si toi tu
intéresser une apparition au chat et à
venir donc on appelle ça sera une
semaine de part entière à marrakech du 7
au 14 octobre prochain il y aura 25
cartes cours d'échecs il y aura des
visites prévues deux demi journées sans
pension d'une belle hotel & spa 4
étoiles tout ça ou ça c'est cool nous
très juste âge c'est 500 euros ht le
prix du voyage qui compte 1 3 db à
puis les jours passent et surtout ça
augmente mais je pense pour 150 euros
retrouvés pas forcément c'est pas
forcément vrai pour l'avion femmes moi
j'ai vu que ça y est c'est par rapport à
mon je voulais acheter en fait les
billets puisque après tu es un petit
changement de dates de trucs et en fait
je vois que ça monte et ça descend en
fait ça dépend de l'aéroport d'où tu
pars en fait voguer voilà mon envol en
gros affronter un coup au tour 2011 les
1120 mais voilà donc ces châteaux 14 se
fera et vacances ces échecs comme d'hab
on a toujours ce tournoi c'est cool mais
quand on parle échec variante moins d'un
coup on est sérieux on sert d'apprendre
le plus de choses possibles déjà prévu
et m
on va les voir sur sur le la page
le site internet de caves donc échec et
un vidéo échec comme un k way
voilà vous à tous les biens chaise
chaque fois sous l'eau vidéos youtube il
ya toute façon votre les points focaux
diriger et donc si ça vous intéresse
vous êtes les bienvenus évidemment à
temps on fera sans doute stage à
l'avenir après du camp nou
mais michael byrns pas un autre registre
est que marrakech oscars et entraîné des
courts sur gk hors kiosque harriott
tarik peu près 1
et sinon j'ai quatre des troncs fra
david centre non plus sa voix hors des
courts soit pour des soirées cool ou les
rend une carte du g4 mais on va pas
faire de cours sur la grotte pendant nos
stages ça sera pas
les cours officiels explique voilà stage
au maroc après outre les deux stages
s'apprête je sais qu'une milliers
d'euros ces gamines une dépense presse
je trouve pas sa charte tous que c'est
le package mais à part les sortir après
voilà aussi prouver notre vie on est
dessus
en plus son propre ami doute ses 500 le
stage on paye nos charges notre
entrepreneur machin ok ben ça c'est pas
non plus démentiel ce qu'on demande
après on fait aussi les master classes
donc si le principe c'est qu'on donne
des cours sur internet des courtiers en
vous une heure et demie heure 45
on en fait par mois donc sans direction
internet après peut y avoir les rediff
aussi vous êtes intéressé écrivez nous
il n'y a pas de souci donc voilà ça
coûte 10 euros les deux master class ou
faire qu'une 6e heureusement il ya
différents thèmes avaient déjà fait du
réseau les platanes 3,4 au centre
entache développement tout ça donc je
faisais de de coire dessus j'ai fait la
défense française
d'abord permettre de thèmes différente
si ça vous intéresse et que vous n'êtes
pas refaire une semaine à peine une
semaine de vacances ou quoi copions sa
première à marrakech vous aussi cette
option à 100 chez vous tranquille en
deux fois une heure et demie voilà voilà
pour un petit côté public les dernières
parties je reviens sur une défaite et
c'est dommage parce que je réussis une
petite remonte à la et je suis à 25,60
et dim 12 monde pourquoi est ce au maroc
et en france bat simplement fait vrai
que le coût de l'hôtel plaza hôtel 4
étoiles bel hôtel spa il ya qui
indiquerait un truc
et attention un camp de détention je
crois plutôt poussif quatre cent vingt
ou trente ans chambre simple facile de
partager la chambre en 355 en gros
on repasse des récompenses enfin si on
comprendre vitalisant formule 1 tout
comme ça pour moi c'est une taxe mais en
quoi trop liquide et après le frais de
déplacement qu'on vous dise et 150 euros
près tu prends le train en france ses
ventes et sur place nous c'est cela
c'est gratuit mais si tu fais dans les
médias ont fait le stage à khaldé de
paris où quoi prendre le train ou
l'avion 1,59 à les payer de façon moins
et hôtel à cannes après oignies sur coup
qui fait un peu je pense qu'on va pas
faire un buteur des chèques par jour
l'idée c'est d'aller un peu les deux
déjà 25 heures des chefs c'est pas mal
mais ça afin de découvrir un pays
passait des vacances de notre demi gens
hésitent à cali enfin des trucs comme ça
et tout ça en fait on peut parler même
tarif si on fait en france on a un
guiderait luz pasqua qui aura quelqu'un
je sais pas il faut que j'aille me dit
je veux une bêtise mais je suis quasi
sûr ça je ne savais pas en fait je suis
même pas du goût de gagner le guide je
savais pas les essieux son chai mais
enfin fassi remarque c'est logique mais
non c'est une fan page a pas deux
je n'ai pas j'ai pas eu besoin de l'idée
du ventre c'était sur thomson et au
tennis parce qu'on a
mon ami lee donc un ami à moi donc les
joueurs d'échecs qui est passé de 1300
là qui travaillent une belle agence de
voyage ou quatre pieds aussi nous avons
un truc que j'ai pas en france du tout
donc voilà l'explication cuba après
nantes fut si loin pas de découvrir un
autre pays pour un panel de gens il fera
beau enfin notre table on est alors en
france faut déjà se couvrir la base pas
climat c'est qu'au bon qu'à ce côté là
les chèques-vacances visite c'était ça
l'idée
mais rien ne dit qu'on fera pas qu'un
message en france un de ces jours après
d'autre que ce qu'on attend de contacts
dans le milieu de l'hôtellerie choses
comme ça si jamais dans le chatt
quelques icônes al way we ce qui a été
dit m quoi qu'il arrive acteurs si
jamais si jamais quelqu'un d'un chat à
des plantes d'intérieur 60 jours fin
diplomate la scène premier votre cette
idée reste à bien donc ça indique romain
passionnant qu'une autre fois on a
peut-être d'autres idées à l'avenir la
réponse à ce palace on en parle dans sa
posture donnera peut-être une bonne
surprise pour 2018
enfin des conseils n'entrait pas une
surprise même mais bon ouais bah c'est
vraiment décevant
là c'est un truc un truc énorme
non ma femme on est à 25 et le lien pour
le stage et après congés ainsi les
restaure casalta sont à adapter les
cours aussi qu'ils sont cool
ben voilà c'est 10 euros à chaque fois
par mois pas trop élevé voilà 25 ans
mais c'est une belle petite soirée
cowell bien pour les courses
voilà sinon demain on essaiera les 26 la
prochaine fois
ouais chez moi de remonter fois dense et
faisable mais c'est juste qu'il faut que
je récupère je récupère ma faim et
peut-être les adversaires chiites
métiers des fois aussi qu'on ne choisit
pas tes adversaires tue pas c'est moins
évident parfois tu vas pas un mec tue-le
tue-le défense dans l'impression d'être
dont tu parles de poker les cas limites
à 3,6 nos limites et
[Musique]
et en mtt ok bah écoutez on va vous
laisser parler ses antennes de check
point comme un truc anglophone j'imagine
tout cas je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée à tous
et puis on se retrouve bientôt
attachons-nous sur les chaînes enfin sur
la chaîne youtube avec les vidéos
après semaine prochaine qu'elle devra
compter qu'elles soient nomades verne et
donc moi je ne suis pas quand je vois le
stream
alors à bientôt soixante voilà voilà
et que d une bonne soirée à vous tout
l'intérêt qu'il ya à bientôt